[Music]
welcome to Tucker Carlson a lot going on
tonight it's been an almost unbelievable
24 hours news Christmas but we're gonna
begin this evening with the most
predictable thing that's happened to
headline you could have written with
total confidence months ago President
Trump acquitted by US Senate just
happened impeachment is finally over the
result was never in doubt the whole
thing was like watching Titanic really
oh pretty gripping but no matter what
happens in the opening scenes you know
the boat is going to sink in the end
same in Washington no matter how firmly
Democrats wished otherwise the president
was always going to remain anonymous and
as predicted both impeachment articles
failed in the Senate obstruction of
Congress went down 53 to 47 the abuse of
power charge failed 52 to 48 a lone
Republican as you may have read defected
and joined the Democrats that Senator
shall go unnamed on this show on the
grounds that silly moral preening should
not be rewarded with the publicity it is
designed to garner an overwrought ethics
lecture from a private equity guy next
thing you know some payday loans
sleazeball will be telling us we're all
going to hell it's just too absurd even
for the ludicrous moment we're living in
we'll take that seriously just as soon
as we decide that al Sharpton is a
legitimate moral voice so enough of that
back in reality though now that
impeachment is over maybe we can have
our country back from last September
until today Ukraine was the only thing
that mattered in Washington that's an
awful lot of wasted time for perspective
it's more time that America spent
declaring fighting and winning the
spanish-american war so what do we get
for it in the end
well nothing really no tangible benefits
at all we did learn quite a bit about
some of the characters involved in the
farce we found out that Adam Schiff is a
budding thespian who knew we also
learned that Nancy Pelosi isn't simply
the leader of a political party she's
also a woman of profound faith as well
as bottomless sadness her days are
consumed by praying and weeping
this is a very sad time for our country
I say this to you with great sorrow and
prayerfully but first let me say that
this is no cause for any joy this is a
very sad time for our country
it's really sad we have to be very
prayerful I pray for the president all
the time this is a very sad time for our
country this there's no joy in this it's
sad Wow not a breezy person that Nancy
Pelosi thankfully now that impeachment
has ended [ __ ] can resume her life of
spiritual contemplation she'll be
returning to her vestry duties at the
Church of third-trimester abortion on
Market Street and we wish her well if
there's any good news to come from
impeachment it's that we now know what
really matters to our leaders in
Washington
if you guessed your safety happiness and
well-being we're gonna have to pause
here to giggle bitterly it's definitely
not that sorry what really matters them
and you've learned this is the nation of
Ukraine which is somewhere near Russia
as we've often been told these past five
months it is our highest and most sacred
duty to support the people of Ukraine
and needles to say that includes giving
them sophisticated weapons systems
whenever they ask for them and never
ever delaying the delivery of those
weapons even for a moment listen to
honorary Ukrainian Adam Schiff explain
the widely accepted fact of Ukraine's
importance to our national security
makes president Trump's abuse of power
and withholding of vital diplomatic and
military support all the more disturbing
we only deter Russia by consistently
demonstrating support for our friends
friends like Ukraine that is why it is
so important to our security that we
stand with Ukraine countries like
Ukraine are fighting our fight against
authoritarianism and god help us if it's
not our fight still god help us if we
ever abandon Ukraine hilarious
imagine if Democrats had gone in another
more conventional direction like drop
the Ukraine talk and instead spent the
last five months working on I don't know
the student loan disaster or lowering
insurance premiums or
helping young people build functioning
families they could have done that but
they didn't they ignored it instead they
gam heard on for months about some
meaningless phone call with the
Ukrainian nobody outside Twitter ever
cared not for one minute the country was
always bored by this and after a few
months
voters became annoyed and then they
became disgusted and the final result
was as predictable as today's vote was
new Gallup poll shows the president with
the highest approval rating of his
presidency higher than the day he was
inaugurated who did that Democrats did
that if Pietschmann didn't just fail it
helped the man they say they hate but
you shouldn't be surprised of course it
did like Titanic the ending was obvious
from the opening credits only they
didn't get it